Hey,
what's going on is bill burn is time for the Monday morning podcast from my
Monday.
Um,
was it April?
We're going to go with April,
April 25th,
2016 what's going on?
Hello?
How are you?
How I,
yeah.
Um,
I just got back from Iowa,
uh,
connected to Phoenix,
could not get a direct flight out of Des Moines,
des Moines International Airport in De Moines,
Iowa.
One of the greatest international airports you'll ever go to.
My hotel was right next door to it.
I was,
I was there for about three hours before the show.
Okay.
I think I heard three jets take off.
That's fucking awesome.
It's a decent size airport too,
but there's very little people you know,
come out on in cornfields,
you know,
getting out of their death metal fucking band rehearsal and going to the de
Moines international airport to fucking go anywhere evidently,
um,
breezed right through security,
all the whole thing.
I love fucking,
I love little airports.
Um,
I love him the way some of these chicks loved that dude who left at fucking band
that was poor fucking little girls.
Oh,
goody two.
Um,
what if fucked up parents film their kids in embarrassing moment.
I can see if siblings do it,
but it always seems like a lot of parents,
they just film their fucking kids and it's just like all those girls who fucking
got filmed or film themselves,
you really should take it down.
But once it's up to you,
get you finished,
you fucking done.
You can't run for president with that on your fucking profile history.
I wonder who's gonna be the first one to run for president.
Right.
And then they just pull up,
uh,
you know,
some clip from the childhood on Facebook or on Youtube assumption,
some video of them either saying something fucked up or getting hit in the balls
and then crying like a little girl or something like that.
You know,
you remember that time when that fucking,
that fat kid through that thing at the little kid and the kid ran over and he
threw the skateboard at him and the kid fucking fell down and let out a cry leg.
I can't even fucking do it in that moment.
That kid's life is far as any sort of leadership role is over,
you know,
and I know what you're saying,
you go well look at him,
bellies out dairy and rank Danks running around with this high pitch voice.
Who's going to follow that into battle?
It's like people fucking develop later in life.
You know,
you should have seen me when I was a kid.
A better yet.
It was good thing you didn't fucking orange hair,
you know,
fucking total introvert,
lunatic,
lunatic.
Literally could not talk to a girl without my face turned beet red.
I was a fucking mess.
If there was fucking videos of that or all the fucking ass kickings I took,
I remember a girl beat me up enough when I was in third grade.
This fifth grade girl beat me up cause I was playing with this kickball and her
sister came up,
was playfully taken it away from me.
So I ran up to take it back and she was running along the school and I ripped it
out of her hands.
You know,
you used to play with boys and she's Kinda careened into the side of the school,
which of course is made of brick cause you know,
if it catches fire,
you know,
you want something to be able to rebuild on,
I mean all those rugs and everybody inside are going to go up like a fucking
bowling alley.
But you want the main structure because the town's got to pay for it.
So anyways,
she goes into the building,
hit her head and as I'm like,
Oh fuck,
I'm sorry.
Her fucking sister showed up and there's a big difference between third grade
and fifth grade.
She looked like a substitute teacher.
I mean that's how much fucking older she looked at me and she fucking just rain
these fucking punches down on me.
And uh,
I held it together,
you know,
I,
I waited till the end of the round.
I knew I was going to lose the decision and I was all right.
I was trying to walk it off.
It really fucking hurt.
And then some girls,
I forget what she said to me,
but it actually made me cry.
She said something supportive.
I have no idea.
So,
um,
yeah.
Now if there was video of that,
I mean that's it.
If they ever had,
I mean there's a guy you are running the country,
get beat up by a girl and start crying.
Okay.
Hi.
How's he going to keep America safe?
How's he going to keep children safe?
How's he going to keep Jesus safe?
And then that's going to be ended at the end of it.
All these fucking people.
You've just film your fucking kids.
Okay.
All is oversharing.
I don't give a fuck that your kids 13 years old is in love with a boy band.
Stopped filming the fuck.
I mean I,
I'm not talking about the kids who filmed themselves,
but just sometimes it's parents,
which is really weird.
Like I hate those families that I'll get into their care van and they start
singing songs or doing dances and that just,
wow.
That's the funnest family ever.
You know,
I can see through it.
the second the camera turns off,
the dad turns into Joe Jackson
so beaten their ass is all over the fucking house.
Um,
anyway,
sorry that was just a complete,
a complete left turn.
But
I dunno,
I'm actually fascinated with that dude leaving the boy band if the height of
their fucking popularity,
you know,
just as far as you know,
being in the entertainment business going,
all right,
and how do you do this?
Did he make enough fucking money?
You know,
Goddamn well his manager and everyone around them stole from the guy.
Did he make enough fucking money?
Yeah.
The thing about it is,
is he's so young,
he's going to look like that guy for a while.
So it's not like,
you know,
he's at that age where he could just slip back into the,
uh,
you know,
like at my age I'm going to be 48 and 10 years.
I'll be 58.
I'm going to little away fucking different.
Okay.
48 is the last sort of like,
you know,
I could go down and maybe play some pickup hoop and I could get picked last.
That's it.
And then 48 to 58 that's,
you know,
when you start getting the chicken neck,
you start getting your affairs in order.
It was kids like fucking 21,
you know,
it's barely going to be 30,
right?
A little over 30 I should say.
So if I was him,
I would shave off dead fucking facial hair and I would just start eating
Mcdonald's and I've just become a fat fuck.
And then I just wait to see how,
why you don't have to be a fat guy.
If you're a fat guy,
then
okay.
Danielle,
like feel like famous in a different way.
Like everybody looks at you but you don't have a show,
you know,
if you get to that level of fat,
all right,
don't get like circus fat.
Yeah,
that'd be funny if he did that and it was just so good at everything.
He became like the fattest guy ever,
you know?
And then everyone was staring at him again.
He's just like,
fuck,
I just,
I can't not be famous.
Um,
anyways,
good luck to that kid.
And,
and parents take,
take down the fucking videos.
You got damn kids,
you fucking Weirdos.
There's probably some pervert out there that likes to jerk off to fucking girls
crying to boy band members who just left.
It was probably a fetish at this point,
you know,
it's nothing else left to jerk off you Korea new,
literally create a new type of porn.
All right.
Anyways,
plow plowed ahead.
Now I know what all you guys take.
I'm going to talk about,
you know,
yeah,
we're going to be like,
oh I saw a big sports story.
Oh boy.
I hope it,
I hope he didn't fucking record as podcast before that went down.
Well I didn't,
I didn't.
Okay.
I will talk about that later.
I just don't give a fuck the way I used to.
Um,
but let's get to what I really give a shit about.
It's only two things I give a fuck about right now.
Gay seven in Saint Louis.
Yeah.
And fucking gave five back in Atlanta.
Okay.
The Boston Celtics.
I missed every fucking second of the last two games cause I was on the road.
I missed all of them.
It was fucking driving.
I didn't have my foam ra,
so my fucking leg was going down.
Now my head to fucking pull over at a rest area,
you know,
stretch it out,
you know what I mean?
Keep my head on a swivel looking for fucking truckers,
questioning their sexuality and fucking a,
what are they?
These serial killers,
Sierra kill his love of fucking rest area.
So anyways,
um,
I missed,
I missed all of that.
All I know is that they came back,
they tied it up.
I was so happy and I did see the clip of whoever that was,
was it a smart on the fucking smart on the Celtics,
barely getting touched and literally throwing himself out of bounds.
I mean,
I know he got fined five grand.
They should've given them at least like $1,000 off just cause he kind of hurt
himself.
He went up so high.
That was one of the worst fucking dives I've ever seen in my life.
And uh,
I mean,
I even think for the Celtics probably teased him about that by the time we got
the locker room.
It's like Jesus Christ who just flopped to the ground.
He fucking jumping up in the air.
Um,
anyways,
and the St Louis Blues,
what the fuck?
You know,
I already went to a heartache with my team.
I fucking hitch my wagon to you guys.
You get up three to one.
I knew,
I fucking knew they had to win game five,
game five,
you know,
so fucked up about a seven game series is you're up three games to fucking one
and you thinking like,
oh we got do is just fucking when one,
no,
you fucking have to won game five because the second you don't win game five the
last two games,
the pressure's on you.
All of a sudden it goes home and wait a minute.
[inaudible] five bar bill.
The other guys,
when the next game
tied up in a,
you know,
I'll tell you right now,
Chicago Blackhawks chapter momentum going into game seven,
the Seiko with blues have a history of playoff collapses.
You know,
that's all it is.
Say It on the fucking,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
I had such belief in this team.
I still believe me when I'm fucking three games to one and I was sitting there
and I said,
without a doubt,
I said,
the fucking Celtics,
we're gonna win game three.
I called it and then I talked shit.
And I said,
like I said,
the self do,
so we're going to win game three,
the fucking Saint Louis Blues are going to win game six.
And they were up three to one before I went on stage and Kansas City.
Uh,
and I was thinking like,
all right,
they got that fucking,
was it Elliot net?
He's playing great,
they got date,
you have a size advantage,
Yada Yada.
I'd like to think of this looks pretty good.
So I go on stage,
right?
I do my Shit Dick Jokes for about a good hour and a half.
I come off the stage,
had a great fucking show and I walk in the green room and all the fucking a
Black Hawk's ski of fucking cheese in ear to ear grin.
The cut to Mike Milburn and I see a final score was also like six to three.
And I was just like,
what the fuck happened?
Tell you what happened.
Five minutes.
It's fucking goals is what happened.
I've yet to see the highlights of that.
But,
um,
I'm recording my podcast right now and I'm getting,
then I got to go over to the writer's room here,
working on episode three written by yours truly for next season.
Who hypes a cartoon fucking 13 months before it comes out this guy.
Um,
and then I'm going to be a,
I'm taping the blues game so I'm not going to be on Twitter or any of that shit
just in case you guys,
uh,
you know,
semi scores and shit,
but I'm going to,
I can't wait to fucking watch that game.
It's going to be great either way.
I want to see St Louis Win,
but uh,
you just have to respect the fucking greatness of the Chicago Blackhawks during
this era.
If they come back from this.
I mean,
it's just,
you know,
it goes beyond in I,
you got to have guys like that guy said,
have one fucking,
what do they went to already?
Two or three,
two,
I think they should.
And they still want to win more.
Very rare.
It's very rare.
Most of the times the guy wins one,
he's done,
you know,
or he wins three.
And he just says,
fuck.
And he keeps eating until his belt buckle bursts.
That's what usually fucking happens with superstars.
Um,
so anyways,
I can't wait to see that.
And then,
uh,
the game game five of the Celtics is tomorrow night,
so I'll be taping both of those.
Um,
this is such a fucking great time of year.
So a little bit of advertising a Sherry's berries are right.
Uh,
there's no,
there's no one quite like mom.
All right.
That started creepy.
Every mom is unique and we wouldn't want to change a thing to talk about your
mom or your wife's quirks.
Why do they fucking do that?
No,
I'm not going to.
And with mother's Day,
just around the corner,
I have a great way to show you,
to show mom how much you appreciate her.
Surprise.
I shouldn't read that.
Done that Tom Brady ship.
Before I got into this,
I'm going to be in a mood.
All right?
And with mother's Day,
just around the corner,
I have a gripe.
I have a great way to show to show mom how much you appreciate her.
Surprise bomb was something unexpected and as unique as she is,
Sherry's berries,
Mommy,
I love you to death.
You are as unique is chocolate covered strawberries.
That's where I put you on the fucking pyramid.
It goes,
you,
you're,
you're in tie.
You're a tie with chocolate covered strawberries.
All right,
right now,
get Sherry's berries,
freshly dipped strawberries starting at 1999 plus shipping or double the berries
for only $10 more.
This is an exclusive offer for my listeners.
Go to Barry's dot com click on the microphone at the top right corner of and
type in my code burr Barry's dipped in milk,
white and dark,
chocolatey goodness,
top with rich chocolate chips.
Chopped nuts since says signature swizzles.
Huge,
fresh,
delicious,
juicy,
delicious.
You pick the delivery date you want and this guarantee,
customer satisfaction is always guaranteed or your money back.
It's a win win.
Here's the only way to get this amazing deal,
freshly dipped strawberries starting at only 1999 or double the berries for just
$10 more.
This is an exclusive offer for my listeners only and every other podcasts that
they advertise on.
When you use my code burpee,
you are our visits,
berries.com B e r r I e s.com.
Click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and click and birth.
That's berries.com.
Click on the microphone and enter the code.
[inaudible] this is a limited time offer and mother's Day is next week.
Make sure to order now they're fucking delicious.
So everybody tells me,
everybody tells me that fucking delicious.
They have Falken delish uh,
but you know,
you might want to get her a fucking brush too or something.
You know my one.
I'm just saying.
You know what I mean?
Get a little,
little more bang for your book.
Ah,
all right.
Pro Flowers,
everybody slow flowers.
Toro pro flowers.
Mom has always been an expert on everything.
Cooking,
relationship advice,
fixing your cuts and bruises.
Talk about your mom,
wife.
Why did they do that?
The only,
yeah.
Oh,
I'll tell you.
I remember one time I got hit by a car,
you know.
Well,
I got hit by a jeep and I buy bike was all fucked up and I was knocked out for a
second.
And then I woke up in the middle of the street laying on the double line that
got out and this guy got out of the jeep crying going,
oh my God,
I hit him,
I hit him.
And then I went under the house and I was like,
mom,
I got hit by a car.
And she's like,
well that's what you get for not looking both ways.
You idiot.
And I was like,
you know what?
Someday I'm going to have a successful podcast and I'm sending her flowers.
Sorry,
I just had to,
I had to um,
honor my contract there and tell that a personal story about my mom or my wife.
One thing you care,
you can't go to her for advice on is what?
To give her up,
get her for mother's Day,
not to worry.
You'll look like an expert on mother's Day when you use pro flowers.
Get Mom 100 blooms with a free glass vase for only 1999 plus shipping and
handling or make her day extra special.
Upgrade to a premium vase and add gourmet chocolates for just 999 more.
Go to proflowers.com today and use my code burr.
You choose the delivery date you want and it's guaranteed it's a no brainer.
Here's the only way to get 100 blooms with the free glass face
starting@nineteenninetyninevisitproflowers.com click on the blue microphone in
the top right hand corner and typing bur bur that's Plouffe.
proflowers.com click on the microphone and type and Burry,
Yada Yada fucking yacht.
All right.
Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody.
Mommy,
more of these.
There's two more.
We'll do two and two toe in toe.
Um,
all right.
Where are we?
Where the hell are we?
There it is.
Sorry.
I had to put the advertising,
everything on the same fucking thing.
Um,
oh by the way,
Jesus Christ.
What a fucking week.
Huh?
With a prince dying,
Mike God watching all those,
uh,
those clips of him
just lit it.
You know what?
I never fucking saw him in concert.
He came out here and did like 20 shows,
sold out at the,
uh,
the La Forum.
I remember Neil went and I was just,
I forget what the fuck I was just on the road.
Okay.
It was like the first couple of nights I had gigs still out here and then I
left,
you know,
for like did a like a 10 day run and he knocked out all those shows us some shit
and I came back and I remember thinking,
ah,
you know,
and I'll catch him on the next one.
And unfortunately that's not how life works.
And um,
I get to tell you though,
like
the level that that guy affected people,
I mean,
they literally lit up the Eiffel Tower in purple.
as far as an artist,
that's about us.
It's about as big as honor as you get all these
like monuments around the world getting lit up and purple man.
I had like,
I knew that we loved him here.
I had no idea.
Like the level of fame that that guy had.
Man.
It's fucking crazy.
So
mmm.
57,
Jesus Christ.
I'm 48.
That's all I was thinking like,
good Lord.
I've got to lay off the sauce.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
I want to thank everybody came out to all my,
my shows this,
uh,
this past weekend,
um,
had a great fucking time play one of the most beautiful theaters I've ever
played to play the Fox theater in Saint Louis and they take you upstairs and if
you ever get a chance to take a tour of the place,
you have to see some of the signatures that are on the wall.
Please don't sign the fucking wall.
It's like fucking people did that next to like Stevie Ray Vaughan.
Like one of my pet peeves is when somebody fucking huge signs of wall and then
all these fucking jerk offs,
right?
Like within the name.
You know what I mean?
It's like you're nowhere near that guy.
Get the sign on the same fucking wall.
Um,
David Bowie was really cool.
David Bowie actually sign next to his name,
but he just scribbled it.
She can't even tell it.
So I'm a fucking hypocrite.
So I signed near his,
but a,
what was so cool was the whole Stevie Ray David Bowie story from back in the day
when a Stevie ray went to,
was it the Monterey Jazz Festival?
And they got booed off stage and David Bowie was in the crowd,
but love Steve.
He's playing.
Um,
and afterwards came up to him and blah,
blah,
blah.
That's how we ended up playing on his let's dance album.
And then he wanted Stevie to go out on tour with them and Stevie just wasn't
feeling it.
He went to some of the rehearsals and just like,
I can't fucking do this.
I want to go back to Texas and play in my trio.
Started all over again and then,
um,
became a giant on his own rather than being part of David's band.
And,
uh,
just the two of them,
just to be that close.
Like,
what was Jerry Lewis?
MMM,
of course.
Now I'm,
I forget Sammy Davis Jr Tony Orlando.
Just some,
a bunch of random shit too.
And all this shit from the 80s,
like the Thompson twins,
all this crazy stuff in there.
Um,
and they really kept it well.
And Stevie signed it twice,
once in 1987 and then another time,
um,
I think right before he died and like the instep tour and,
I got there a little bit late,
so I didn't get a chance to see the theater,
like the actual theater where people were sitting,
thank God until after I did the show.
Cause that would have been a little intimidating.
I'm came out afterwards,
it was fucking amazing and,
um,
had a great show.
And then the next day I went to,
uh,
went to Kansas City and played this sprint.
And,
um,
I did a run with a Jay cat,
a Predator and um,
we were going to,
we wanted to get barbecue and we try to figure out where to go.
That's right.
And they told us to go to that fucking Oklahoma Joe's or some shit.
So we fucking pull up there and um,
there's like a fucking two hour line outside the place.
And I'm just sitting there like,
there's no fucking way this is the line for this place.
But the royals had a game.
So I guess it's like a family tradition out there.
People just do that shit.
So we were like,
well fuck that place.
So the next place I had on my list to maybe try out was this other place,
Q 39.
And um,
it's the best barbecue I've had since saws when I was in Alabama.
It was fucking,
it was the best.
I will say it's the best brisket I ever had.
We both ordered a couple of combo plates.
So,
um,
you know,
we ended up having to smoke chicken brisket ribs and
the fuck else was there.
Oh.
And of course pulled pork and it was fucking amazing.
But I have to tell you,
dude,
right after that,
man,
I felt like I,
I've,
I just,
I'm too old to eat like that.
I mean,
I'll spare you the fucking details,
but my body was just like,
yeah,
you know,
you have a,
see somebody show up at a club and they're already drunk.
Like how quickly they get thrown back out into traffic.
Yeah.
That,
that's what happened with me.
It was not a,
it was not a good thing.
Um,
was not a good thing at all.
So anyways,
uh,
but it was delicious and I didn't even eat that much.
Oh,
wait a minute.
Now he did.
Then we got dessert too.
Yeah,
it was kind of a bad day.
It was a bad thing,
but it was funny.
I didn't eat shit for the rest of the fucking night,
but,
um,
I had a great time,
uh,
later on that night,
hung out with a bunch of friends.
I've been going to Kansas City for a long time.
So,
uh,
at a buddy of mine out there who built my first website,
him and his wife showed up.
So we were just hanging out,
having drinks,
just having a great time.
And then the last day was I got to go up to Iowa and a ames,
Iowa,
just north of de Moines.
And I finally went to that state during a sunny month and it was green and it
was fucking beautiful.
And,
uh,
de Moines really underrated city.
Fucking gorgeous river runs right through it and they got this beautiful two
mile loop that you can walk around.
I wish I had time to do that.
I forgot that that was there.
I had,
like I said,
I hadn't been in Iowa since I played penguins and Cedar rapids,
which I heard is no longer there because the river overflowed or some shit.
Um,
but anyways,
just had a,
uh,
had a great time up there and I gotta tell you that's the fucking place to own a
Ferrari Iowa.
That is the fucking place placement because I,
you see people riding around on a motorcycle with no helmets on and shit.
That is the place to own a motorcycle that is the place to own a fucking super
car.
That is the fucking place to own a gun.
You have to have a gun.
These fucking at console live on the coast and they're all jammed in with
people.
It makes sense that you don't want everybody having a gun.
All right.
But this is tipping point where the population becomes so fucking little that
then you're kind of on your own out there.
All right?
So if you fucking weird ass neighbor shows up dressed like leathers,
face,
I mean you're going to call the fucking cops by the time I was joking on stage,
by the time they drive up your driveway,
like half your family is fucking dead.
Their driveways,
I swear to God,
some of these,
some of these spreads are like,
uh,
I dunno if they're like fucking,
they look like they're like,
like you could land a Goddamn DC 10 on the damn thing.
So,
um,
all right,
so here it is.
The big news,
the big news this week that I found when I got up right was a,
actually I didn't find it till I connect to deck,
flew from De Moines to Phoenix and then I connected,
um,
you know,
get my connecting flight and it was late and I looked at my Twitter and people
started sending me all this shit about Tom Brady,
the suspension,
somehow some hour came back.
It fucking blew my mind.
I was always under the impression that like either way,
once you appealed it,
that last thing was the final thing.
I've never seen an appeal of an appeal.
Maybe there's been one.
I just remember what,
I remember when Al Davis wanted to move the Raiders and they're like,
no,
you can't do it.
And he goes,
well I'm fucking doing it anyways.
And then they had a court battle and he won and that was it.
The NFL just said fine.
Um,
maybe there was a bunch of appeals on that,
but that one came out of nowhere.
And um,
I dunno man,
I don't want to sit here and fucking be a big baby about it or anything like
that,
but I did just really seems like it just went above and beyond.
It's just really extra.
I don't,
I don't understand.
I don't get the fucking NFL.
I really don't.
I don't get why certain things,
you know,
your knock a woman out in an elevator,
you get four games,
you get two games at first,
right.
Then they bumped it up to four cause everybody bitched and then they like,
oh no,
wait a minute.
Wait.
And we mean you're,
you're out of football for good.
You know,
the subtext of that of course was now we're going to lose a bunch of fucking
money from women and guys who remotely give a shit about women aren't going to
buy our fucking jerseys and shit.
So now all of a sudden we give a shit.
Right?
Um,
so I just have to think that this really isn't a money thing.
They actually lose money when Tom's not playing.
So I really think this is just personal.
The Patriots did something to piss off the fucking NFL.
I know a lot of you guys who aren't patriots fans think I'm just trying to make
up an excuse.
But the reality is,
is the NFL,
the only thing they give a fuck about is money.
All right?
The way they handled all those concussions,
the way they finally did that bullshit payout,
the way they make money off of a raising cancer awareness by having pink
jerseys,
not letting you know that only 3% of the or whatever goes to
research and they pocket the other 97% the way whenever they put a camera on,
you know,
the servicemen and women that they hooked up,
gave them free tickets,
give them a round of applause.
And then they count that as a fucking commercial and they charge whatever branch
of service those people are in.
You know,
how filthy they are there and only give a fuck about money.
Tom Brady's captain America,
like the Patriots and not guy looks like a movie star and they make more money
if he's in the game and you're talking about literally a cons,
hairs worth of air.
They,
they appealed it and won and the NFL still was like,
no,
fuck you.
Fuck you.
So,
um,
I,
it's just,
it has to be personal because,
and I don't want to name any fucking names here.
Okay.
There's other guys just as big as him who had some really questionable fucking
shit that went way beyond fucking air pressure in a ball.
All right.
And it was just like,
yeah,
whatever.
No biggie,
no blood,
no foul.
So,
um,
yeah,
I think it's official at this point that as a patriots fan,
I am not paranoid when I say the NFL fucking hates the Patriots and has it out
for them because they're actually shooting themselves in the foot monetarily
here over fucking air pressure over something that they lost in court and like a
fucking year ago.
So,
um,
I dunno,
I dunno what we did.
I would love to know behind that
the scenes,
it's gotta be some Robert Kraft Shit,
I would think,
you know,
I can't really think of anything else because,
I'm trying to be honest here,
but like,
you know,
some of the other infractions,
okay.
Without naming names,
I'm trying to be a class act here of certain things that went through the mail,
wink,
you know,
just shit like that and it's just nothing.
No story.
Um,
and not to mention,
you know,
the cults owner in his own fucking investigation,
they found out that for their footballs were also under inflated.
So,
okay.
Did you read talking about going on almost a year and a half ago that this
happened?
This shit's still fucking go.
And so,
I mean,
all right.
The NFL hates us and know Tom Brady for four games.
I guess that's,
you know,
whatever.
We're still going to win.
What too good.
We're still going to fucking win.
All you're going to do is just make bill Belicheck a better fucking coach and he
already prepared for this last year,
so when we get fucking Janeane Garofalo in there again,
I think he goes to and to,
I'm looking forward to it.
Um,
all right,
there you go.
There's all of that type of stuff.
Uh,
what a fucking weekend I had,
man,
I,
I can't tell you how much fun I had going out there and,
um,
uh,
doing those shows,
man,
and,
uh,
working on my act and all that is great.
I have like,
I have the best fucking life I could possibly have.
Uh,
right now I'm writing on this the exact fucking show I want to do with a bunch
of hilarious people during the week and every other week I get to continue my
dream doing standup comedy.
So,
um,
and I'm working towards taping another space,
spatial special later on this year.
And I'm also starting to get the audio together for hopefully a vinyl release
of,
uh,
my show at Madison Square Garden.
Obviously I want that one to come out after my standup special,
but uh,
you know,
I'm hoping to do like a,
like I'm not going to say what I'm hoping to do with that vinyl album,
but a,
it's going to be fucking cool if I do it right.
If I don't fuck it up.
All right.
So anyways,
here we go.
Let's read some questions here for the week.
A bill,
when I travel out of town for games,
I bring the stick.
Oh,
this is about foam rollers.
Um,
cause dude,
I'm telling you,
that foam roller changed my fucking life.
Any old people out there like me?
If you're young,
you should fucking do it.
It's the greatest God damn thing ever.
There's nothing better than like I,
you know,
other than eating right in that type of stuff,
um,
finding love and not having your quarterback suspended for four games over some
country air pressure,
there's nothing better than,
um,
than it just being able to move your fucking body and stretching is the best
really.
Yoga,
pilates,
all of that shit is probably the best shit you can do because it really keeps
you in shape.
It really keeps you flexible without hurting yourself.
I can't help it.
I'm a child of the 80s,
so I'll always have that world Jim gold gym.
Push it up,
don't pay it.
Okay.
I always have to fucking,
you know,
do it.
What do,
what do you benching?
What are you benching their kid?
I always had this always going to be in B.
Um,
but anyways,
these foam rollers,
I'm telling you that if they're the shit,
so,
but I never heard of this.
This kid's recommending the stick.
Doesn't sound like a paid advertisement.
It isn't.
He said,
I can fit it in my carry on you.
It'd be great as if this kid invented it and he's actually getting a free
commercial.
He said,
I can fit it in my carry on or in my gear bag.
Um,
so it travels a lot better than any foam roller and it's a lot easier to do just
sitting in a chair and not having to roll around on the floor.
You might like it.
Uh,
it's what keeps me functional when I have three of four hurling games,
crazy ancient Irish sport to play in a day at a tournament.
Well,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Wait.
I gotta look this up.
You know,
if it's an Irish sport,
you know,
two things,
it's fucking crazy and you know,
there's nobody stretching hurling thing and show somebody puking.
Okay.
It's an Irish game resembling field hockey.
All right.
I'm not trying to start anything with Ireland,
but uh,
that's a woman's sport over here.
They run around wearing skirts and I know you guys don't do the kilt thing.
So what the fuck is going on?
All right.
Played with the shortest stick and a broader oval blade.
It's a national game of Ireland and may date back to the second millennium BC.
All right,
so you're all forgiven.
You didn't know any better.
All right,
let's see some images for this thing.
Oh fuck that.
That's not a,
that's a club.
I would play that fucking game.
That is a fucking club.
Jesus Christ.
Look at those fucking helmets they wear.
It looked like fucking butch goring.
And then somebody took a welding class for the first time ever.
Butch Goring's hockey helmet.
Butch scorings hockey helmet.
By the way.
It is legendary.
He had the same piece of shit helmet I think for right up from the juniors.
And um,
he just paint every time he went to a new team,
he would just paint it.
I remember he finished with the,
uh,
did he finish with the Bruins?
I remember he played with us.
Oh,
those were the days.
those were the days Jesus Christ.
Look at this guy taken one of those fucking paddles right to the face.
Um,
wow.
Okay.
I get shit faced and watch that.
That is the weirdest looking thing I've ever seen.
It's like,
it looks like the beginning of a goalie stick and then you amputated it.
Right.
Just beyond the heel,
about a third of the way up the blade.
Um,
all right,
so let's get,
you know what dude,
I really appreciate that.
I'm going to check that out.
Um,
the stick good stuff.
Thank you.
All right.
China by Billy boy.
I'm Iranian living in China.
Jesus,
he goes,
yeah,
right.
Iranian.
I think the only place that you might not have any fans is North Korea and
that's only because they don't have access to the Internet.
Um,
anyways,
I have watched,
I'll,
speaking of which jade,
who I worked with this week is Brazilian and she mentioned,
you know,
she was thinking about maybe doing some standup down in Brazil and how that
scene is starting to get going.
And I,
I was just wondering,
anybody from Brazil listening and if you do,
if you have any suggestions,
um,
cause I've always wanted to take my wife down there.
She's always wanting to go and uh,
I'd love to go down there.
I guess it's cold this time of year,
right?
My wife's not into the cold.
I personally like it.
You know what I mean?
That's all good for me.
Um,
I got no problem with that whatsoever,
but,
uh,
let me know what's going on down there and I'm psyched you guys are getting some
standup shit going.
Cause I'd like to see your Chappelle's Louis C K s and David tells us what I'm
looking forward to all these like India and all these places that are starting
to get comedians.
I can't wait to see the grates that come out of those,
uh,
those different cultures.
Um,
all right.
So anyways,
let me continue on here.
Anyways,
I've watched all your videos on Youtube and followed your podcast for more than
six months.
Uh,
you are indeed a funny guy though.
My Chinese wife does not get your jokes.
Women around the world do not like my act.
I should charge her,
change her to one with better tastes.
I think he's given me shit.
There.
He goes.
I think you have so many fans here,
especially among ex patriots.
Well,
if you're in Hong Kong,
yeah,
I did a show out there.
He goes,
uh,
I don't know if you've ever been in China,
but really hope,
uh,
you get your ass here someday looking forward to hear back from you.
Please fuck yourself every day in the morning before breakfast.
Um,
yeah,
I was in Hong Kong last year.
I'd never been to the mainland,
but I heard when you go to the mainland,
it's just straight Chinese,
you know what I mean?
Like all the expatriates seemed to be in Hong Kong,
so I would go to mainland China,
but I just feel like other than seeing the Great Wall and eating some delicious
food,
I don't think I could do a show up there cause I didn't want to be worried that
not enough people would be able to understand what I'm saying and even if they
could understand it,
I think maybe I just,
I dunno,
I think they'd be like your wife.
Like I don't get what he's talking about.
Um,
anyways.
Okay.
Continuing on Hillary hot sauce,
old hot sauce.
Hillary.
Um,
you know,
Billy,
listen to your Thursday podcast in the bit about Hillary and the hot sauce is
actually true.
Um,
there are interviews with her talking about this over a decade or so.
Apparently in the 90s she learned how healthy it was,
dede hot peppers.
And so she did and she grew to love hot sauce.
It's also known that she kept a lot of hot sauces at the White House where she
lived.
Anyways,
for some reason I felt bad for her,
so I thought I'd write you well,
here's the fucking thing.
You know what?
You know what I like?
I like fried chicken.
Okay.
I would never bring that up if I was talking to a bunch of black people trying
to get their votes,
you know what I mean?
Even if she is into it,
which you just say she is fine,
it's still a fuck.
It was,
it was just tacky.
A hot sauce.
I always had it,
you know,
it wasn't lipstick.
It wasn't anything like that.
All the other bullshit that she has.
Um,
yeah,
I just don't buy it.
And um,
I just think they're lying sacks of shit and I've had 20 years experience
watching them on TV.
I lived in New York when she was a center there at center there.
I watched Bill Clinton for eight fucking years.
I can't stand them.
I think they'll literally fucking say anything.
I think they're bought and paid for it.
They are the fucking devil.
Not Literally,
they're evil,
but they're just the same evil that you're dealing with.
And it doesn't make a difference that she's black and she's got a dick or a
vagina.
It's going to be more of the same if you pick her.
And I think that's why you have to fucking extreme people.
I think people are sick of that.
And that's why Bernie still in it.
And Trump is still in it because I think generally speaking,
people know that whatever the fuck we're doing,
it's not working.
It's not fucking working.
So,
and maybe it's not,
maybe nobody can fix it.
You know what I mean?
You've got fucking,
what,
a four,
500 million people you can get to all the go get them all to try to tug the rope
in the same direction.
I mean,
that's,
it's a very difficult thing to do it.
Uh,
I don't know.
I just wish the election was tomorrow.
We could just get it over with.
I saw this funny sign on the Internet and he said 2016 everybody sucks.
Or something like that.
Something about all the candidates.
Nobody isn't,
I don't know.
I butchered it.
I have to do,
you know what I want to make up for me?
Just butcher in that thing.
I might have to put the,
uh,
the picture of it,
which I probably won't be able to find,
so I think I'll just have to take it,
um,
that I fucked that up.
All right,
let's read the last two were advertising's here advertisements.
Advertising's Sherry's berries.
What the fuck are they?
God Damn it.
All right.
Here we go.
Oh,
I should probably make a prediction here,
right?
MMM.
I don't know how to,
you don't,
I'd have no prediction for game seven.
I want the blues to win.
MMM.
Fuck.
You know what?
Fuck it.
I'm not gonna say anything.
Cause at this point,
blues fans are gonna hate me if I fucking predict them again.
You know people get all fucking with that Mojo Shit.
You're going to jinx him.
Fuck it.
I'm just going to watch the game.
All right.
Dollar Shave club,
everybody.
Dollar Shave club.com as a special offer for new members who join today,
you'll get a free month of the exit of the executive razor razor when you buy a
tub of Dr Carver's shave butter,
also known as Doc Dick Cavett.
Easy say,
this is the first time they've ever done something like this and once you try
dollar Shave Club doc,
why don't you try dollar shave club.com you'll become a proud member like
millions of others.
One reason is because they deliver amazing razors right to your door for a third
of the price of what the greedy razor corporations charge that.
That means when you join dollar Shave Club,
you can afford to shave with a fresh blade anytime you want,
which feels phenomenal.
You'll get a first class shave when you use the executive blade without hurting
your wallet.
Another reason is their doctor candidates,
e Shea butter.
Using it with the executive razor,
it makes the blade glide gently for the smoothest shave ever.
Dr Carver's shave butter isn't your average shave cream.
It's a unique condition conditioning formula with high quality natural
ingredients,
leaving his skin unbelievably soft and smooth.
Uh,
and right now,
new members,
we'll get a tub of shave butter and get the executive razor for free.
They've made,
they've never done this before.
Take advantage of it and it's only available by going to dollar shave
club.com/burr.
That's dollar shave club.com/burr.
All right,
blue apron.
Okay.
You need to learn how to cook and need to know how to cook.
I should say,
not only do you like,
uh,
do you feel like you know your way around a kitchen?
But cooking at home means eating healthier and saving money instead of ordering
expensive takeout.
Again,
we're,
where do you start?
Blue Apron has you covered for less than $10 per meal.
Blue Apron delivers all fresh ingredients,
all the fresh ingredients you need to create home cooked meals.
Just follow the easy step by step instructions.
Each meal can be prepared in 40 minutes or less.
No overwhelming trips to the grocery store.
No more sad.
No matter your your dietary preferences.
Blue Apron makes it a breeze to discover and prepare dishes like pan roasted
chicken with Lance,
Seattle,
Kale and Blue Potato Hash.
I can't even say half this shit.
I saw Marin posted a picture.
It looked delicious.
Brothy Yuzu cod was soba noodles locked in?
Is this even real stuff?
Use juice and Soba noodles.
Steak and grains of Paradise and Mash Plan.
Tanes pink lemon question mark.
I don't know what your shit the fuck do I know.
Oh,
Rose Kohn,
polo cod fish and chips with a Aioli.
I know that word.
Pork Roast in whole roasted carrots with Brown buttered spinach.
I fuck it.
I get it.
Keys with Teekay products.
Am I really supposed to read all of this spinach with red lettuce,
spice chick pea burgers.
I'm gonna start crying here with fat Ovid.
Sweet potatoes,
mad
lemon yogurt sauce,
Kale.
We fucking get it was soft boiled eggs and Keanu or and all that.
Hey,
whether where the fuck's the rest of the copy?
I Dunno.
Go to blue apron.com/bar.
Click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in Burp.
I hope that's what I was supposed to say.
Um,
Jesus Christ,
they'd like typed the whole fucking menu.
Okay.
I was introduced in the fucking Wu Tang.
Um,
all right.
Gash,
cash and banking.
I listened to your podcast today and about about money.
How is just a number while relating to paychecks?
I couldn't agree more.
Um,
that they are intentionally phasing out cash period.
Every payday.
I go to the bank and I take out all of my cash except what is needed to cover my
bills and the bank.
People look at me like I'm an idiot on a regular basis.
I walk out of there with seven to eight grand in cash at least once or twice a
month and they actually interrogate me about why I'm taking all my money out of
the bank and how come I don't need my money in the bank?
All my friends think I'm a conspiracy theorist because I buy silver by the pound
and other precious metals.
Dude,
you need to shut up.
Stop telling your friends that you do this shit.
You're,
you're opening yourself up to get robbed.
All right.
Just act like you just taken everything down to the fucking bank.
Why are you telling me this?
All right.
All my friends think I'm a conspirator that by silver I got,
I refuse to keep money in the bank and if we ever go into a great depression of
the government collapses,
they're going to seize everybody's money in the bank accounts guaranteed.
Uh,
so I'll keep all my cash hidden at home,
which if the currency crashes really in the end it doesn't do me any good
because it won't be worth shit.
But I don't like the government to know how much money I have in any given
moment.
I think it's a good practice.
So yeah,
I think people should take their money out of the bank.
Every payday,
actual physical money and dollar bills.
Plus when I had the cash in my hand and I run out of it,
there's no way I can spend more than I have.
I also believe in credit cards.
Everything I bought was with cash,
even cars,
$30,000 cars bought with cash.
It may throw up a few red flags but fuck them.
No it doesn't,
not if you're,
you know,
if you're paying taxes on all,
once you deposit it in the bank,
there's a record of it.
And um,
I think the banks want to know what you're doing with it.
They always want to know what you're doing with your money cause they want to
make money off your money.
So what you do every week by giving them money is you give them an interest free
loan on their money.
I guess they give you a couple of points interest.
Um,
they provide the service of keeping your money safe,
allegedly even though there a bunch of crooks and then they load loan it out to
your fellow countrymen.
It super high rates and you know,
this is nothing to,
if you put seven,
eight grand in there,
they can loan seven,
8,000 big and 100% loan out all that money.
Like,
I dunno,
like times three or some,
some shit.
It's crazy.
Back in the day,
like when you ran a bank responsibly,
what it safe,
he had 10 grand in the bank.
You could only loan out like there was a certain percentage,
you couldn't go past like 30%.
I can't remember what it was,
but you know,
so the money was still there and they,
the bankers through paying off politicians kept getting that money,
that number,
that percentage,
um,
bumped up and up and up and up.
And they kept getting more and more deregulated,
more and more deregulated.
Now when you put the money in,
they can loan it,
you put a thousand in,
they can loan,
they can loan out.
Not only a hundred percent of that thousand,
they can loan like another $3,000 off of that thousand thousand for you,
you,
you when you,
um,
so they basically counterfeited length three grant.
As far as the shit that I've read,
and I haven't looked that stuff up for a while.
Things might've changed after 2008.
But it's a,
it's a pretty shady thing.
But I will tell you,
I don't feel comfortable having a bunch of cash in the fucking house,
you know?
Uh,
I always hear the first 48 playing in my head.
So,
you know,
good luck to you.
You know what I did after a while?
I just tapped out of conspiracy theory.
I got a fucking dog.
I watched sports and I just,
I,
I'm just,
I take comfort knowing that it can only die once.
That's what I do.
All right?
Okay.
Oh,
Jesus.
Another fucking hair loss thing.
It's just to me.
Another guy asked me,
should he shaved my head?
Should I not shave my head?
She like glue something on there.
Hey.
Oh,
flowers for billion.
Uh,
I'll keep it short.
Parentheses and thinning.
I've been losing my hair for the past couple of years.
It's thinning at the top and has been doing so for six years.
Um,
I know you've gone through the same predicament.
Aww.
You're very perceptive.
I'm going to go out on a limb.
I think.
I know.
I think you know what I'm talking about here.
He goes,
I am.
I know it shouldn't matter.
And should,
I should probably just shave it.
But I love my hair.
My God.
Do I love my hair?
I remember when I used to get my hair cut every Barbara's stylists,
this stylist I went to said how it was so thick and I would never have to worry
about going bald.
Those lying fucks.
So when it started thinning,
I,
I like most guys started reading everything I could.
I found out that most men have had success with Propecia.
It's a one day a pill that you take 60% of men every growth while 30% keep what
they have.
Um,
and what does that mean?
60% of regrowth in 30% of that 60%
yeah.
I guess that that would be,
yeah,
that's obvious.
What that be.
Keep what they have no.
Or is that the other 30 60% keep what they have.
Oh,
60% Jesus Christ bill have regrowth.
30% keep what they have.
So now where are we up to 90% yeah,
I guess we would be,
and it seems not to work for about 10% of men.
So it seems like a no brainer to at least try,
right.
Well,
for about 2% of men.
All right dude,
you said 60,
30,
10 and now too,
we're up to 102% here.
So there's some fucking overlap.
Um,
it makes their dick not work.
They complain of a weaker to know erections.
Um,
since look up.
Look sir,
this is fucking hilarious.
See,
keep your hair to get the girls could come home and then your Dick doesn't work.
Uh,
that's exactly why I don't fuck with that shit cause she can never have your
cake and eat it.
So I just feel like there's gotta be some sort of damage that it does.
I just,
you know,
dude,
I'm 48 years old.
What am I going to join a boy band?
It's fucking over.
Do you know,
I gotta be honest with you.
If you don't fight aging,
it's pretty painless.
You know,
I go to the gym,
you know,
I keep myself in good shape at all of that other shit.
These fucking,
this fucking woman was telling me this weekend that,
that out here in Hollywood,
you know,
approximately around the country.
I don't know they have,
this is the mode is the most disgusting thing as far as vanity,
I think I've,
I've heard in a long time,
do you know they have,
they have botox parties.
Okay.
Like they come over,
they drink drinks,
they watch a show or something like that and then you can go over and Kiki yet
like that shit that makes you face look like the joker just shot into your face.
Like this foreign chemical under your skin.
Yeah.
You know,
I guess it's your skull right there and it is protecting your brain.
But I just feel like somehow it's got a leak in there.
Right.
Or it goes into your fucking bloodstream or something.
Somehow it ends up in your brain.
I just seen you just literally injecting chemicals into your fucking face.
It's the amount of people that won't do heroin,
but we'll put botox in their body.
It's just,
I dunno,
I guess it's whatever the fuck you're into.
Um,
yeah,
I dunno.
I like I said,
if he just,
except the fact,
okay,
that,
you know,
you're no longer young and your dress your age,
you,
you don't look that you have to keep yourself in shape.
You,
you look fine.
You know what I mean?
You don't look sexy.
You're not attractive,
but you shouldn't be.
You should have gotten all that out of your fucking system.
This whole fucking thing that you got,
like these,
these,
you know,
these broads on the fucking a real housewives walking around with their but
dazzled jeans.
Like I like four kids and they're still fucking putting,
you know,
hooker jeans on.
It's like,
what are you doing?
You're a mom.
You know,
the husband's walking around with fucking tank tops on.
I just don't under is put on a sport coat.
He supposed to be adults.
I Dunno.
I blamed Madonna.
Um,
no I don't.
She looks great.
What am I talking about?
You know,
he goes,
well,
what the fuck?
What the fuck?
Shut up.
It's still bagger.
All right,
Sudbury,
the ugliest place in Ontario,
Canada.
A dear Billy burr.
Please talk about your experience traveling through Sudbury.
I didn't think it was ugly.
I thought it was cool.
Did you notice how there were no trees in the area above 10 feet tall or so?
Most of the vegetation in the area was destroyed by acid rain be caused by the
massive,
um,
mining operations in and around Sudbury.
Our stupid tourist attraction is the largest nickel in the world.
Luckily,
they solved the population problem by building a gigantic smokestack.
Currently the second largest freestanding Shim the in the world to spread the
pollution out over a larger area.
Industry has been winding down.
So now we have more unemployed,
hardworking Canadian rednecks and ever great place.
Can't wait to get anywhere else.
Uh,
it's fucking hilarious.
Okay.
I have person may have a future as a writer.
Mancy I'll fucking Kuma works when you hate where you live.
I didn't hate where I live,
but I mean there's just certain things I could fucking bring it out of you.
Um,
I had no idea.
I didn't know any,
I didn't think about that.
I had a great time when I was up there.
And,
uh,
you know,
I'm a nerd when it comes to traveling.
I like going to places I haven't been to.
And at this point there's nothing I like doing better than not going to the
major city.
Um,
my bend all of them a thousand fucking times.
They're great.
But,
um,
I dunno,
I like going to,
I like going to the other places.
De Moines deadwood,
right.
Is that when I went to when fucking Louisiana begins with an s,
I can't remember.
It wasn't New Orleans.
That doesn't begin with an s Schenectady.
Shreveport.
Right.
That'll fucking know.
Anyways,
uh,
open relations.
Hi there,
Billy bald bags.
Uh,
what the fuck is up with open relationships these days?
I'm a 37 year old lady,
unexpectedly widow.
I'm sorry to hear that.
And after eight years,
after eight years with my husband,
uh,
I'm getting back out there in the dating world and have discovered a plus
plethora of people who are in an open or polyamorous relationships.
Okay.
I Dunno what polyamorous mates.
All right.
Open relationship means like,
yeah.
You know,
keep it clean.
I don't want to know about it.
Uh,
don't make,
make sure it's nobody I know.
Polyamorous m or uh,
do do,
do,
do is a practice or desire for intimate relationships evolving more than two
people also they have threesomes together.
MMM.
It's so fucking weird.
Does a couple like break down the game tape afterwards?
Like I just felt like you licked her pussy.
Let her be better than mine.
You know?
Do you make like halftime adjustments when you switch and positions?
Yeah.
MMM.
Open relationship.
Does it get me in trouble?
Rules to be looking at this online.
This is my search engine.
Oh.
For relationship.
Six rules of,
for doing the whole open relation thing,
right.
One,
don't do it too.
Don't do it.
All right.
Open relationship.
Alright.
Okay.
Here we go.
One,
understand what an open relationship actually is.
Uh,
there's a lot of confusion,
confusion,
confusion about what is and what isn't an open relationship.
Some people who are in long distance relationships say they're in an open
relationship.
They both hook up with whoever,
but just don't talk about it by the word open connotes honesty.
RSC.
They have to know about an open relationship and knowledge as a couples can have
their needs met by other people.
If you're really okay with that,
why keep it a secret?
All right.
Um,
it's actually a great point.
If you are okay with it,
it shouldn't bug you.
Did you do today honey?
I had some chick blow me on the way home and I got a pizza.
Oh,
that's great.
I take thunder games,
hunger games,
whatever the fuck they call funder games.
Um,
make sure you're doing it right,
doing it for the right reasons.
Are you interested in an open relationship just because you want to be with
other people or is it that you're interested in physical experiences with other
people,
but you want to stay committed to sharing your emotional and spiritual self with
one's process where it gets complicated?
Set some boundaries.
No Anal.
Every person,
every person's guidelines are different.
But there are always things to think about before you enter into an open
relationship.
Um,
do you both need to be present in order for sex with other people to be okay?
Can you be with one gender and not the other or certain sector acts off the
table.
These are all important things.
Uh,
this is just like the early days at USC.
All right.
No more eye gouging.
You can't do that thing where the other guy puts the finger in your ass and then
you go,
all right,
I give,
I give right.
That's actually a wrestling move.
He can believe it.
Um,
anyone you hooked,
tell your other partners.
Anyone you hook up with outside of relationship deserves to know the deal.
Try say something like,
I find you attractive,
but you should know my partner and I are in an open relationship,
so there's someone else in my life.
That way they can be fully informed.
Okay,
keep it healthy.
If that's obvious.
Have regular checkups.
There you go.
All right,
so now that I'm a little more fucking educated,
what the fuck did that just say?
Oh,
60 turn ons for better sex.
I thought it was the turn ons for over 60.
I think I am a little dyslexic.
I'm all right.
So she says she's getting in there and everybody.
Okay,
so there's a bunch of like husbands and wives looking to hookup with her or
people who was saying that they're an open relationship.
She goes,
I read this recently,
started dating a great guy who lives with the mother of his kids and his
supposedly sexless domestic partnership.
We have a great connection and we enjoy each other's company,
but he doesn't have a lot of extra chill time due to his family commitments.
I have kids too,
the same age as his even.
I keep telling him,
let's all hang out together,
but he is hesitant,
which makes me question the openness of his open relationship or maybe he just
wants to fuck you.
All right.
I keep telling us,
hang out together.
Okay.
I should have walked away sooner,
but he gives really good head.
Jesus Christ.
I'm not ready for anything too serious.
I just wish she had more time to spend with me socially.
This seems to be more and more common.
These I'm so cool and modern.
I'm going to fuck you and then go home to my wife.
Hipsters.
Should I keep seeing this guy?
Uh,
thanks for,
and your insight in the form of Bostonian living in Hawaii.
I'm a huge fan.
You keep me laughing through some hard times and I fucking love your old
freckled face more.
Uh,
thank you.
Um,
I would say a yeah,
I,
I dunno,
that's all fucking you look if you just want to fuck around.
But like this guy obviously does,
he obviously doesn't want to do anything more.
Even if he didn't have a,
wasn't with somebody else.
If he doesn't want to hang out with you,
then that means he just wants to be fuck buddies,
which is totally cool if you know that that's the deal.
If you're all right with that,
I would continue seeing him.
If you're not,
I would move on.
And if you sick a meeting,
people like that,
I'm sure there's men who,
um,
that didn't work.
I was gonna say,
men who are sick of meeting women who are in an open relationship.
Yeah.
Guys will be like,
yeah,
that's cool.
You don't want to hang out
up top.
Sounds good to me.
Um,
yeah.
I W I if you're your age,
how busy you are and all that shit,
and I'm not trying to be a dick.
I'm 10 years old.
And he said,
I'm not talking down to you.
You're 37.
You got fucking kids,
kinds of people.
You're gonna meet in the civilian world are also going to be married with kids
of saying or divorced.
I mean,
um,
I would join,
I would join a dating site.
That's what I would do.
And uh,
just say what you want and I would fucking go out and try and find it when
you're ready,
when you're ready.
But um,
you know,
as far as all that other shit,
I mean,
that's
up to you.
I have no,
I have no fucking idea.
That just made me happy then I'm fucking married.
Um,
and that Jesus Christ more and more fucking brutal.
God Damn Shit I might even get into,
I know you guys all heard
some sad news about comedians this past week,
man.
Just fucking brutal.
Absolutely fucking brutal.
Maybe,
uh,
feel very lucky and blessed.
So once again,
thank you to everybody that keeps coming out to my shows and,
um,
that's it.
That's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.
And,
um,
that's it.
Don't take any shit out day.
You fucking cunt.